[Aplausos]
la duma rusa prohibió la propaganda lgtv
entre adultos la prohibición ampliaría
la restricción vigente de lo que las
autoridades llaman propaganda de
relaciones sexuales no tradicionales a
menores adoptada por el kremlin en 2013
ahora el nuevo proyecto Busca prohibir
la difusión de dicha información a
personas de todas las edades expertos
consideran que la ley amplía la
represión contra la perseguida comunidad
lgbtimás
Durante los últimos meses hemos
escuchado explicaciones muy diferentes
sobre Cuáles son las razones del
conflicto entre Rusia y Ucrania y la más
reciente y la que está ganando
popularidad entre la propaganda Estatal
es la explicación de que en realidad es
una guerra de Rusia contra occidente
unificado por los valores tradicionales
la tercera y última lectura de la ley
aprobada por la cámara baja todavía debe
ser revisada por la cámara alta del
parlamento y firmada por el presidente
Vladimir Putin antes de que entre en
vigor los parlamentarios dicen que la
legislatura defiende la moralidad del
país y aisla los valores decadentes no
rusos promovidos por occidente este
discurso sobre los valores tradicionales
que busca preservar una forma
tradicional de familia por supuesto es
justamente el que se ha propagado en
toda Rusia y el que también se está
propagando en otros países vecinos
recordemos que Hungría Polonia y
recientemente Rumanía también tuvieron
intenciones de crear leyes parecidas
entonces lo que hace esto es crear una
suerte de efecto dominó que empieza a
expandir este pensamiento en otros
lugares y al ser las organizaciones
activistas organizaciones que están en
la posición vulnerable frente al
gobierno autoritario de Putin pues sin
duda alguna esto es parte por supuesto
de una agenda mucho más grande
los ciudadanos que incumplan podrían ser
merecedores de una multa de hasta 6.600
dólares las personas jurídicas serían
multadas con 82 mil 100 dólares mientras
que la sanción para los extranjeros
serían 15 días de arresto y una
expulsión del país